the man accused of killing four
University of Idaho students returned to
court yesterday Brian kohlberger showed
up with cuts on his face which the
sheriff said came from shaving coburger
is charged with four counts of
first-degree murder and one count of
felony burglary he has not entered a
plea Luciano has more from the hearing
which will be the last one in this case
for a while
in court for the second time since being
extradited to Idaho Brian coburger
appeared calm as he agreed to push his
preliminary hearing to June 26th a move
that's meant to give his defense team
more time to prepare at that point the
state will present some of its evidence
against co-burger to show there's
probable cause for his case to go to
trial it seems like quite a ways out for
that type of hearing Shannon gray is
representing the family of Kaylee
Gonzalez one of the four murdered
victims house that Gonzalez family doing
today you know it's uh it's the same as
always this is going to be a long
journey in the criminal justice system
and they just want to move forward and
get a conviction on this case as for
what to expect from the court date in
June oh good prosecutor at a preliminary
hearing wants to put on one witness if
that's possible one investigator and
give up as little as possible CBS News
legal analyst Ricky cleeman said
coburger's hearing will give the defense
an opportunity to cross-examine the
state's Witnesses and try to poke holes
in their case early on the defense wants
to show that the prosecution has not
done its job meaning it's investigators
likely is the defense Theory zeroed in
on Brian kohlberger and stopped looking
at anybody else and that the factors
they had were coincidental
and Ricky said something that was
interesting too Vlad if there's any
discrepancies between what a what a
witness says during the preliminary
hearing and the trial that witness could
then be impeached easily later on
all right more to come on this story
Lilia thank you very much